The following is a conversation
with Ian Goodfellow.
He is the author of the popular
textbook on deep learning,
simply titled Deep Learning.
He coined the term of
generative adversarial networks,
otherwise known as Ganz and with his 2014
paper is responsible for launching the
incredible growth of research
and innovation. In this
subfield of deep learning.
He got his bs and ms at Stanford,
his Phd at University of Montreal with
Yoshua Bengio and Aaron Kerrville.
He held several research
positions including an open AI,
Google brain and now at apple as
the director of machine learning.
This recording happened while
Ian was still a Google brain,
but we don't talk about it and you
think specific to Google or any other
organization. This conversation is part
of the artificial intelligence podcast.
If you enjoy,
subscribe on Youtube,
iTunes or simply connect with me on
Twitter at Lex Friedman, spelled f,
r I.
D.
And now here's my conversation
with Ian Goodfellow.
You Open your popular deep learning book
with a Russian doll type diagram that
shows deep learning is a subset
of representation learning,
which in turn is a subset of machine
learning. And finally a subset of Ai.
So this kind of implies that there may
be limits to deep learning in the context
of Ai.
So what do you think is the current
limits of deep learning and a,
are those limits something
that we can overcome with time?
Yeah, I think one of the
biggest limitations of deep
learning is the right now it
requires really a lot of data,
especially labeled data.
There are some unsupervised and semi
supervised learning algorithms that can
reduce the amount of label data you need,
but they still require a
lot of unlabeled data. Hmm.
Reinforcement learning algorithms,
they don't need labels,
but they need really a lot of experiences.
Um,
as human beings we don't learn to play
Pong by failing at park 2 million times.
So just getting the generalization ability
better is one of the most important
bottlenecks in the capability
of the technology today.
And then I guess I'd also say deep
learning is like a component of a bigger
system. Um, so far nobody
has really proposing to have,
uh,
only what you'd call deep learning as
the entire ingredient of intelligence.
You use deep learning as sub
modules of other systems,
like Alphago has a deep learning model
that estimates the value function. Um,
most reinforcement learning algorithms
have a deep learning module that
estimates which action to take next,
but he might have other components if
you're basically building a function
estimator.
Do you think it's
possible? He said nobody's kind of
been thinking about this so far,
but do you think you're on that works
could be made to reason in the way
symbolic systems did in the
eighties and nineties to do more,
create more like programs
as opposed to functions? Yeah, I think
we already see that a little bit.
I already kind of think of neural
nets as a kind of of program.
I think of deep learning as basically
learning programs that have more than one
step.
So if you'd draw a flow chart or,
or if you draw a tensor flow graph
describing your machine learning model,
I think of the depth of that graph is
describing the number of steps that run in
sequence and then the width of that
graph has a number of steps that run in
parallel now.
It's been long enough that we've had
deep learning working that it's a little
bit silly to even discuss
shallow learning anymore.
But back when I first got involved in Ai,
when we used machine learning,
we were usually learning things
like support vector machines.
You could have a lot of input features
to the model and you could multiply each
feature by a different weight.
All those multiplication locations were
done in parallel to each other and there
wasn't a lot done in series.
I think.
Well we got with deep learning was
really the ability to have, uh,
steps of a program that run in sequence.
And I think that we've actually started
to see that what's important with deep
learning is more the fact that we have
a multistep program rather than the fact
that we've learned to representation.
If you look at things like a resonance,
for example,
they take one particular
kind of representation and
they update it several times
back when deep learning first really took
off in the academic world in 2006 when
Geoff Hinton showed that you
could train deep belief networks,
everybody who was interested in the idea
thought of it as each layer learns a
different level of abstraction,
that the first layer trained on images,
learn something like edges and
the second layer learns corners.
And eventually you get these kind of
grandmothers sell units that recognize
specific objects.
Today I think most people think of it
more as a computer program where as you
add more layers, you can do more updates
before you output your final number.
But I don't think anybody believes
that layer 150 of their resume yet.
Uh, is a grandfather,
grandmother cell and you know,
layer 100 is contours or
something like that. Okay.
So you think you're not thinking of it
as a singular representation that keeps
building,
you think of it as a program,
sort of almost like a state representation
has a state of understanding.
Yeah,
I think of it as a program that makes
several updates and arrives at better and
better understandings, but it's not
replacing the representation at each step.
It's refining it and in some sense
that's a little bit like reasoning.
It's not reasoning in
the form of deduction,
but it's reasoning in the form of taking
a thought and refining it and refining
it carefully until it's good
enough to use. Do you think,
and I hope you don't mind, we'll jump
philosophical every once in a while.
Do you think a of cognition,
human cognition or even consciousness
as simply a result of this kind of a
sequential sequential
representation learning,
do you think that can emerge?
Okay.
Cognition? Yes, I think so. Consciousness,
that's really hard to even
define what we mean by that.
I guess there's consciousness is often
defined as things like having self
awareness and that's relatively easy
to turn into something actionable for a
computer scientist to reason about
people also defined find consciousness in
terms of having qualitative states
of experience like qual, Leah, right?
There's all these philosophical problems,
like,
could you imagine a Zombie who does all
the same information processing as a
human but doesn't really have the
qualitative experiences that we have,
that sort of thing.
I have no idea how to formalize or
turn it into a scientific question.
I don't know how you could run an
experiment to tell whether a person is a
Zombie or not.
And similarly,
I don't know how you could run an
experiment to tell whether an advanced AI
system had become conscious in
the sense of quality or not.
But in the more practical sense,
like almost like self attention,
you think consciousness and cognition
can in an impressive way emerge from
current types of architectures?
Sure. Yeah. Or, or if,
if you think of consciousness in
terms of self awareness and just, um,
making plans based on the fact that
the agent itself exists in the world
reinforcement learning algorithms that
are already more or less forced to muddle
the agent's effect on the environment
so that that more limited version of
consciousness is already something
that we get limited versions of with
reinforcement learning algorithms
if they're trained well. But, uh,
you say limited.
So the,
the big question really is how you
jumped from limited to human level. Yeah.
Right. And, uh, whether it's
possible the, you know, the,
even just building common sense reasoning
seems to be exceptionally difficult.
So Ken, if we scale things up, if we
get much better on supervised learning,
if we get better at labeling, if
forget, get bigger datasets, uh,
more compute,
do you think we'll start to see really
impressive things that go from limited to,
you know, uh, something echoes
of human level cognition?
I think so. Yeah. I'm,
I'm optimistic about what can happen
just with more computation and more data.
Uh, I do think it'll be important to
get the right kind of data. Today,
most of the machine learning systems we
train are mostly trained on one type of
data for each model.
But the human brain,
we get all of our different senses and
we have many different experiences like,
you know, riding a bike, driving a
car, or talking to people, reading. Um,
I think when you get that kind of
integrated dataset working with a machine
learning model that can actually
close the loop and interact,
we may find that algorithm's not so
different from what we have today.
Learn really interesting things when you
scale them up a lot and train them on a
large amount of multimodal data.
And so multimodal is really interesting.
But within like your work
in a adversarial examples.
So selecting within modal,
within a one mode of data,
uh,
selecting better at what are the difficult
cases when we share most of these
slow to learn from.
Oh yeah.
Like could we could each get a
whole lot of mileage out of uh,
designing a model that's resistant to
adversarial examples or something like
that. But my thinking on that has
evolved a lot over the last few years.
When I asked him,
when I first started to really invest
in studying adversarial examples,
I was thinking of it mostly as adversarial
examples reveal a big problem with
machine learning.
And we would like to close the gap between
how machine learning models respond
to adversarial examples and how humans
respond after studying the problem more.
I still think that adversarial
examples are important.
I think of them now more of as a
security liability then as an issue that
necessarily shows there's something
uniquely wrong with machine learning as
opposed to humans.
Also.
Do you see them as a tool to improve
the performance of the system? Not,
not on the security side,
but literally just accuracy.
I do see them as a kind
of tool on that side,
but maybe not quite as much
as I used to think. Ah,
we've started to find that there's a
trade off between accuracy on adversarial
examples and accuracy on cleaning
samples back in 2014 when I did the first
adversarily trained classifier that
showed resistance to some kinds of
adversarial examples.
It also got better at the clean data
on omnist and that's something we've
replicated several times and feminist,
uh,
that when we train against
weak adversarial examples,
Agnes classifiers get more accurate so
far that hasn't really held up on other
datasets and hasn't held up. When we
train, I get against stronger adversaries.
It seems like when you confront
a really strong adversary, uh,
you tend to have to give something up.
Here's your thing.
But it's such a compelling
idea cause it feels, uh,
it feels like that's how us
humans learn the difficult cases.
We try to think of what would it be,
screw up and then we make
sure we fixed that. Yeah.
It's also in a lot of
branches of engineering,
you do a worst case analysis and make
sure that your system will work in the
worst case and then that
guarantees that it'll work.
And all of the messy average cases that
happen when you go out into a really
randomized world. Yeah. With
driving with autonomous vehicles,
there's seems to be a desire
to just look for think.
Adversarially tried to figure
out how to mess up the system.
And if you can be robust to all
those difficult cases, then you can,
it's a hand wavy, empirical way
to show your system is a, yeah.
Yeah.
Today,
most adversarial example research isn't
really focused on a particular use case,
but there are a lot different use cases
where you'd like to make sure that the
adversary can interfere with the
operation of your system. Like in finance,
if you have an algorithm
making trades for you,
people go to a lot of an effort
to obfuscate their algorithm.
That's both to protect their IP because
you don't want to research and develop a
profitable trading algorithm than
have somebody else capture the gains,
but it's at least partly because you
don't want people to make adversarial
examples that full your algorithm
and to making bad trades
or I guess one area that's been popular
in the academic literature is speech
recognition.
If you use speech recognition to hear
an audio wave form and then in turn that
into a command that a
phone executes for you,
you don't want a malicious adversary
to be able to produce audio.
That gets interpreted
as malicious commands,
especially if a human in the room doesn't
realize that something like that is
happening in speech recognition.
Has there been much success
in being able to uh,
create adversarial examples
that fool the system?
Yeah,
actually I guess the first work that I'm
aware of is a paper called hidden voice
commands that came out in 2016 I believe.
And they were able to show that
they could make sounds that are not
understandable by a human,
but are recognized as the target phrase
that the attacker wants the phone to
recognize it as.
Since then things have gotten a little
bit better on the attacker side.
When worse on the defender side,
it's become possible to make sounds
that sound like normal speech but are
actually interpreted as a
different sentence than the human.
Here's the level of perceptibility of the
adversarial perturbation is still kind
of high, uh, that when you
listened to the recording,
it sounds like there's some noise in the
background just like rustling sounds.
But those wrestling sounds are actually
the adversarial perturbation that makes
the phone here are completely different
sentence. Yeah. That's so fascinating.
Peter Norvig mentioned that you're
writing the deep learning chapter for the
fourth edition of the artificial
intelligence and modern approach book,
so how do you even begin a summarizing?
They feel the deep learning in a chapter?
Well, I am. In my case, I waited like
a year before I actually read anything.
I think it has it even having written
a full length textbook before,
it's still a pretty intimidating to try
to start writing just one chapter that
covers everything.
One thing that helped me make that
plan was actually the experience of,
and having written the full book before
and then watching how the field changed
after the book came out,
I realized there's a lot of topics that
were maybe extraneous and the first book
and just seeing what stood the test of
a few years of being published and what
seems a little bit less important to
have included now help me pare down the
topics I wanted to cover for the pork.
It's also really nice now that the field
has kind of stabilized to the point
where some core ideas from the
1980s are still used today.
When I first started
studying machine learning,
almost everything from the 1980s had
been rejected and now some of it has come
back.
So that stuff that's really stood the
test of time is what I focused on putting
into the book.
There is also I guess two different
philosophies about how you might write a
book,
a one philosophy philosophies.
He tried to write a reference that covers
everything and the other philosophy is
you try to provide a high level summary
that gives people the language to
understand a field and tells them
what the most important concepts are.
The first deep learning
book that I wrote with the,
and Erin was somewhere between the,
the two philosophies that it's trying to
be both a reference and an introductory
guide. Uh, writing this chapter
for Russell and Norvig's book.
I was able to focus more on just a concise
introduction of the key concepts and
the language you need
to read about them more.
And a lot of cases actually
just wrote paragraphs that said,
here's a rapidly evolving area that
you should pay attention to. It's,
it's pointless to try to tell you
what the latest and best version of a,
you know, learn to learn
model is, um, you know, I can,
I can point you to a paper
that's recent right now,
but there isn't a whole lot of a reason
to delve into exactly what's going on
with the latest learning to learn
approach or the latest module produced by
learning to learn algorithm.
You should know that learning to learn
as a thing and that it may very well be
the source of the latest and greatest
convolutional net or recurrent net module
that you would want to use
in your latest project.
But there isn't a lot of point in trying
to summarize exactly which architecture
in which learning approach got
to which level of performance.
So you may be focused more on
the basics of the methodology.
So from backpropagation to feed
forward to recurrent neural networks,
convolutional, that kind of thing.
Yeah. Yeah. So if I were to ask you,
I remember I took a algorithms
and data structures algorithms.
So of course I remember the,
the professor asked what is an algorithm
and a yelled at everybody in a good way
that nobody was answering it correctly.
Everybody knew what the Alpha,
it was a graduate course.
Everybody knew what an algorithm was,
but they weren't able to answer
it. Well. So let me ask you, uh,
in that same spirit,
what is deep learning?
I would say deep learning is any kind of
machine learning that involves learning
parameters of more than
one consecutive step.
So that would mean shallow learning
is things where you learn a lot of
operations that happen in parallel.
You might have a system that
makes multiple steps, um,
and like you might have had
designed extractors, uh,
but really only one step is learning.
Deep learning is anything where you
have multiple operations in sequence and
that includes the things that
are really popular today,
like convolutional networks
and recurrent networks. Uh,
but it also includes some of the
things that have died out, uh,
like bolts and machines where we
weren't using backpropagation today.
I hear a lot of people define
deep learning as gradient
descent applied to these
differentiable functions.
And I think that's a
legitimate usage of the term.
It's just different from the
way that I used the term myself.
So what's an example
of a deep learning that is not Grady and
descendant differentiable functions in
your, I mean, not specifically
perhaps, but more even
looking into the future. What,
what, what's your thought
about that space of approaches?
Yeah, so I tend to think of
machine learning algorithms
is decomposed into really
three different pieces.
There's the model which can be something
like a neural nut or a bolt and machine
or a recurrent model.
And that basically just describes how
do you take data and how do you take
parameters and you know,
what function do you use
to make a prediction given
the data on the parameters.
Um, another piece of the learning
algorithm is the optimization algorithm.
Or not every algorithm can be really
described in terms of optimization.
But what's the algorithm for updating
the parameters or updating whatever the
state of the network is? Uh, and then the,
the last part is the,
the Dataset.
Like how do you actually represent the
world as it comes into your machine
learning system?
Um,
so I think of deep learning as telling
us something about what does the model
look like and basically
to qualify as deep,
I say that it just has to have multiple
layers that can be multiple steps in a
feed forward differentiable computation
that can be multiple layers in a
graphical model.
There's a lot of ways that you could
satisfy me that something has, uh,
multiple steps that are each
parameterized separately.
I think of gradient descent as
being all about that other piece.
The how do you actually
update the parameters piece?
So you could imagine having a deep model
like a convolutional net and training
it with something like evolution
or a genetic algorithm.
And I would say that still
qualifies as deep learning. Uh,
and then in terms of models that
aren't necessarily differentiable, uh,
I guess bolts and machines are probably
the main example of something where you
can't really take a derivative
and use that for the learning
process. Uh, but you,
you can still argue that the model has
many steps of processing that it applies
when you run in France in the model.
So the steps of processing,
that's key.
So Geoff Hinton suggest that we need to
throw away back pop backpropagation and
start all over.
What do you think about that?
What could an alternative direction
of training neural networks look like?
I don't know that backpropagation
is going to go away entirely.
Most of the time when we decided that a
machine learning algorithm isn't on the
critical path to research for improving
AI, the algorithm doesn't die.
It just becomes used for some
specialized set of things.
A lot of algorithms like logistic
regression don't seem that exciting to AI
researchers who are working on things
like speech recognition or autonomous cars
today.
But there's still a lot of
use for logistic regression
and things like analyzing
really noisy data in
medicine and finance or um,
making really rapid predictions in
really time limited contexts. So I think,
I think uh,
backpropagation and gradient descent are
around to stay but they may not end up
being,
um,
everything that we need to get to
real human level or superhuman AI.
Are you optimistic?
Bought us discovering s you know,
backpropagation has been
around for a few decades so uh,
I optimistic about us as a community
being able to discover something better.
Yeah, I am I think, I think we likely
will find something that works better.
You could imagine things like having
stacks of models where some of the lower
level models predict perimeters
of the higher level models.
And so at the top level you're not
learning in terms of literally calculate
ingredients, but just predicting
how different values will perform.
You can kind of see that already in some
areas like Basie and optimization where
you have a Gaussian process that predicts
how well different parameter values
will perform.
We already use those kinds of algorithms
for things like hyper parameter
optimization and in general we know a
lot of things other than back prop that
worked really well for specific problems.
The main thing we haven't found is a way
of taking one of these other non back
prop based algorithms and having it
really advanced the state of the art on an
AI level problem. Right. But I, I,
I wouldn't be surprised if eventually we
find that some of these algorithms that
even the ones that already exist,
not even necessarily a new one,
we might find some way of customizing
one of these algorithms to do something
really interesting at the
level of cognition or, or the,
the level of,
um,
I think one system that we really don't
have working quite right yet is uh,
like short term memory.
We have things like Lstm,
they're called long short term memory.
Uh,
they still don't do quite what a
human does with short term memory.
Um,
like gradient descent to learn a specific
fact has to do multiple steps on that
fact. Like, if I, I tell you,
the meeting today is at 3:00 PM,
um, I don't need to say over and
over again. It's at 3:00 PM 3:00 PM.
It's at 3:00 PM. It's at 3:00 PM for
you to do a great step on each one.
You just hear it once and you remember it.
Um,
there's been some work on things like,
uh, self attention and attention,
like mechanisms like the neural Turing
machine that can write to memory cells
and update themselves with
facts like that right away.
But I don't think we've
really nailed it yet.
And that's one area where I'd imagine
that new optimization algorithms or
different ways of applying
existing optimization
algorithms could give us a way
of just lightening fast updating the
state of a machine learning system to
contain a specific fact like that without
needing to have it presented over and
over and over again.
So some of the success of symbolic
systems in the 80s is they were able to
assemble these kinds of facts, uh, better,
but there's a lot of expert input required
and it's very limited in that sense.
Do you ever look back to that as a
something that will have to return to
eventually sort of dust off
the book from the shelf and uh,
think about how we build knowledge,
representation, knowledge,
you have to use graph
searches and searches, right?
And like first order logic and entailment
and things like that. A thing. Yeah,
exactly.
In my particular line of work,
which has mostly been machine learning,
security and,
and also generative modeling,
I haven't usually found myself moving
in that direction for generative models.
I could see a little bit of, it could
be useful if you had something like a,
a differentiable,
uh,
knowledge base or some
other kind of knowledge base
where it's possible for some
of our fuzzy or machine
learning algorithms to interact
with the knowledge base.
I mean,
you're on that one.
It's kind of like that. It's a
differentiable knowledge base of sorts.
Yeah.
But if we had a really easy way of giving
feedback to machine learning models,
that would clearly help a lot with,
with generative models.
And so you could imagine one way of
getting there would be get a lot better at
natural language processing. But another
way of getting there would be a tick,
some kind of knowledge base and figure
out a way for it to actually interact
with a neural network, being able to have
a chat, we'll then y'all network. Yeah.
So like one thing and generative models
we see a lot today is you'll get things
like faces that are not symmetrical,
like people that have two eyes
that are different colors.
And I mean there are people with eyes
that are different colors in real life,
but not nearly as many of them as you
tend to see in the machine learning
generated data.
So if you had either a knowledge
base that could contain the fact, uh,
people's faces are generally approximately
symmetric and eye color is especially
likely to be the same on both sides.
Uh,
being able to just inject that hint
into the machine learning model without
having to discover that itself after
studying a lot of data would be a really
useful feature.
I could see a lot of ways they're getting
there without bringing back some of
the 1980s technology.
But I also see some ways that you could
imagine extending the 1980s technology
to play nice with neural nets
and have it helped get there.
Awesome. So, uh,
he talked about the story of you coming
up with idea of gans at a bar with some
friends. You were arguing
that this, you know, uh,
gans would work generative adversarial
networks and the others didn't think so.
Then you went home at midnight,
code it up and it worked. So if,
if I was a friend of yours, a at
the bar, I would also have doubts.
It's a really nice idea, but I'm very
skeptical that it would work. Uh,
what was the basis of their skepticism?
What was the basis of your intuition?
Why should work?
I don't want to be somebody
who goes around to promoting
alcohol for the message
of science,
but in this case,
I do actually think that
drinking helped a little bit.
When your inhibitions are lowered,
you're more willing to try out things
that you wouldn't try out otherwise.
So I have noticed in general that
I'm less prone to shooting down.
So am I an idea is when I'm,
when I have had a little bit to drink.
I think if I had had
that idea at lunch time,
yeah it probably would have thought it.
It's hard enough to train wonder.
I'll net you can't train a second neural
net in the inner loop of the outer
neural net.
That was basically my friends objection.
Was that trying to train to neural nets
at the same time, we'd be too hard.
So it was more about the training
process and less so my
skepticism would be, you know,
I'm sure you could train it, but
uh, the thing would converge to,
would not be able to generate
anything reasonable and, and,
and you kind of reasonable realism.
Yeah.
So,
so part of what all of us were thinking
about when we had this conversation was
deep bolts and machines, which a
lot of us in the lab, including me,
we're a big fan of deep
Bolton machines at the time.
They involved two separate
processes running at the same time.
One of them is called the positive phase
where you load data into the model and
tell the model to make
the data more likely.
The other one is called the negative phase
where you draw samples from the model
until the model to make those
samples less likely. Um,
in a deep bolts and machine,
it's not trivial to generate a sample.
You have to actually run an iterative
process that gets better and better
samples coming closer and closer to
the distribution the model represents.
So during the training process,
you're always running these two
systems at the same time, uh,
one that's updating the parameters of the
model and another one that's trying to
generate samples from the model.
And they worked really well
and things like [inaudible],
but a lot of it's in the lab,
including me,
had tried to get people to machines
to scale past feminist to things like
generating color photos and we just
couldn't get the two processes to stay
synchronized. Um, so when
I had the idea for gains,
a lot of people thought
that the discriminator would
have more or less the same
problem as the negative phase.
And the bolts and machine that trying
to train the discriminator in the inner
loop,
you just couldn't get it to keep up with
the generator and the outer loop and
that would prevent it from
converging to anything useful. Yeah,
I share that intuition. Yeah. Um,
well it turns out to not be the,
a lot of the time with
machine learning algorithms,
it's really hard to predict ahead of
time how well they'll actually perform.
Right? You have to just run the
experiment and see what happens.
And I would say I still today don't have
like one factor I can put my finger on
and say,
this is why Ganz worked for
photo generation and deep
bolts and machines don't.
There are a lot of theory papers showing
that under some theoretical settings,
the again algorithm
does actually converge,
but those settings are restricted enough
that they don't necessarily explain the
whole picture in terms of all the
results that we see in practice.
So taking a step back, can you, uh,
in the same way as we've
talked about deep learning,
can you tell me what generative
adversarial networks are? A, yeah.
So generative adversarial networks are
a particular kind of generative model.
A generative model is a machine learning
model that can train on some set of
data.
Like say you have a collection of photos
of cats and you want to generate more
photos of cats or you want to estimate
a probability distribution over cats.
So you can ask how likely it is that
some new images, a photo of a cat, um,
gans are one way of doing this.
Uh,
some generative models are
good at creating new data. Uh,
other generative models
are good at estimating that
density function and telling
you how likely particular pieces of data
are to come from the same distribution
as the training data.
Gans are more focused on generating
samples rather than estimating the density
function. There are some kinds of
gowns like slogan that can do both,
but mostly gowns are about
generating samples, uh,
generating new photos of
cats that look realistic. Uh,
and they do that completely from scratch.
It's analogous to human imagination.
When again creates a new image of a cat.
It's using a neural network to produce
a cat that has not existed before.
It isn't doing something like
compositing photos together. You're not,
you're not literally taking the eye off
of one cat and the Erath off of another
cat. It's, it's more of this
digestive process where the,
the neural net trains in a lot of data
and comes up with some representation of
the probability distribution
and generates entirely new cats.
There are a lot of different ways
of building a generative model.
What's specific to Ganz is that we have
a two player game and the game theoretic
sense and as the players
in this game compete,
one of them becomes able
to generate realistic data.
The first player is called the generator.
It produces output data such
as just images for example.
And at the start of the learning process,
it'll just produce
completely random images.
The other player is
called the discriminator.
The discriminator takes images as input
and guesses whether they're real or fake.
Uh, you train it both on real data. So
photos that come from your training set,
actual photos of cats, and you try
not to say that those are real.
You also train it on images that come
from the generator network and you train
it to say that those are fake.
As the two players compete in this game,
the discriminator tries to become better
at recognizing where their images are
real or fake.
And the genitor becomes better at fooling
the discriminator into thinking that
it's outputs are our real.
Uh,
and you can analyze this through the
language of Game Theory and find that
there's a nash equilibrium where the
generator has captured the correct
probability distribution.
So in the cat example,
it makes perfectly realistic cat photos
and the discriminator is unable to do
better than random
guessing because all the,
all the samples coming from both the data
and the generator look equally likely
to have come from either source.
So do you ever,
do you ever sit back and just blow your
mind that this thing works so from very,
so it's able to estimate that
Desi function enough to generate,
generate realistic images? I mean,
uh, yeah. Do you ever sit back?
How does this even,
why this is quite incredible,
especially where against have gone
in terms of realism. Yeah. And,
and not just a flutter in my own work,
but generative models all over them have
this property that if they really did
what we asked them to do, they would do
nothing but memorize the training data,
right? Um, models that are based
on maximizing the likelihood,
the way that you obtain the maximum
likelihood for a specific training set is
you assign all of your probability mass
to the training examples and nowhere
else, uh, for gans that game
is played using a training set.
So the way that you become unbeatable
in the game is you literally memorized
training examples.
One of my former interns read a paper,
uh,
his name is if I should
not have an Auger Rajan.
And he showed that it's actually hard
for the generator to memorize the try and
get a heart and uh,
a statistical learning theory sense that
you can actually create reasons for why
it would require quite a lot of learning
steps and a lot of observations of,
of different latent variables before
you could memorize the training data.
That still doesn't really explain why
when you produce samples that are new,
why do you get compelling
images rather than just garbage?
That's different from the training set.
And I don't think we really
have a good answer for that,
especially if you think about how many
possible images are out there and how few
images the generative
model sees during training.
It seems just unreasonable that generative
models create new images as well as
they do,
especially considering that we're
basically training them to memorize rather
than generalized.
Uh,
I think part of the answer is there's a
paper called deep image prior where they
show that you can take a convolutional
net and you don't even need to learn the
parameters of it at all.
You just use the model architecture and
it's already useful for things like in
painting images.
I think that shows us that
the convolutional network
architecture captures
something really important
about the structure of images.
And we don't need to actually use the
learning to capture all the information
coming out of the convolutional
net. Uh, that would,
that would imply that it would be much
harder to make generative models and
other domains.
So far we're able to make reasonable
speech models and things like that.
But to be honest,
we haven't actually explored a whole lot
of different data sets all that much.
We don't, for example, see a
lot of deep learning models of,
um,
like biology datasets where you have lots
of microarrays measuring the amount of
different enzymes and things like that.
So we may find that some of the progress
that we've seen for images and speech
turns out to really rely heavily
on the model architecture.
And we were able to do what we did for
vision by trying to reverse engineer the
human visual system. Right.
Um, and, and maybe it'll turn
out that we can't just, uh,
use that same trick for
arbitrary kinds of data.
Right? So there's aspects
of the human vision system,
the hardware of it that
makes it without learning,
with all cognition just makes it really
effective at detecting the patterns
we've seen. The visual world.
Yeah. That's, yeah, that's
really interesting. Uh, what,
um,
in a big
quick overview,
in your view and your view,
what types of gangs are there and what
other generative models besides Gans are
there?
Yeah. Um, so it's maybe a
little bit easier to start with.
What kinds of generative models
are there other than cans? Um,
so most generative models are
likelihood based where to train them.
You have a model that tells you how,
how much probability to signs
to a particular example,
and you just maximize the probability
assigned to all the training examples.
It turns out that it's hard to design a
model that can create really complicated
images,
are really complicated audio wave
forms and still have it be possible to
estimate the likelihood function
from a computational point of view.
Uh,
most interesting models that
you would just write down.
Intuitively it turns out that it's almost
impossible to calculate the amount of
probability they assigned
to a particular point. Um,
so there's a few different
schools of generative models
in the likelihood family.
Uh, one approach is to very carefully
designed the model so that it is
computationally tractable
to measure the density,
to assign to a particular point.
So there are things like, uh,
auto regressive models
like Pixel, CNN, uh,
those basically break down the probability
distribution into a product over
every single feature.
So for an image,
you estimate the probability of each
pixel given all of the pixels that came
before it. Uh, there's tricks where if
you want to measure the density function,
you can actually calculate the
density for all these pixels,
more or less in parallel,
uh,
generating the image still tends to
require you to go one pixel at a time,
and that can be very
slow. Uh, but there again,
tricks for doing this in a hierarchical
pattern where you can keep the runtime
under control or the quality of the
images the generates putting runtime aside
pretty good. Uh, they're,
they're reasonable. Yeah.
I would say a lot of the best
results are from gans these days,
but it can be hard to tell how much of
that is based on who's studying which
type of algorithm, if that makes sense.
The amount of effort and invest in empty.
Yeah. Or, or like the kind of expertise.
So a lot of people who have traditionally
been excited about graphics or art and
things like that have gotten interested
in gans and to some extent it's hard to
tell are gans doing better,
uh,
because they have a lot of graphics and
art experts behind them or are against
doing better because
they're more computationally
efficient or are against doing
better because they prioritize
the realism of samples. All right.
Over the accuracy of that
density function. I think,
I think all of those are potentially
valid explanations and it's,
it's hard to tell.
So can you give a brief history
of gans from 2014 we paid for 13.
Yeah.
Um,
so a few highlights in the first paper
we just showed that gans basically work,
if you look back at the samples we had
now they look terrible on the CFR 10 data
set. You can't even recognize
objects in them. Your paper, sorry.
It'll use see far 10. We Use Eminence,
which is a little handwritten digits. Uh,
we use the Toronto face database,
which is small grayscale photos of faces.
We did have recognizable faces.
My colleague Bing Shoe put together the
first Gan face model for that paper.
Um,
we also had the CFR 10 data set,
which is things like very small,
32 by 32 pixels of, of uh,
cars and cats and dogs have for that.
We didn't get recognizable objects,
but all the deep learning people back
then were really used to looking at these
failed samples and kind of
reading them like tea leaves.
And people who are used to reading the
tea leaves recognize that our tea leaves
at least look different, right?
Maybe not necessarily better,
but there was something unusual about them
and that got a lot of us excited.
Uh,
one of the next really big steps was lept
gown by Emily Denton and Sumif tele at
Facebook AI research where they actually
got really good high resolution photos
working with gangs for the first time.
They had a complicated system where they
generated the image starting at low Rez
and then scaling up to high res. Uh,
but they were able to get it to work.
And then, um, in 2015,
I believe later that same year,
uh,
Alec Radford and [inaudible]
Chin Tele and Luke mets, uh,
published the DC Gann paper,
which it stands for deep convolutional,
again,
it's kind of a non unique name because
these days basically all gans and even
some before that were deepened
convolutional, but, uh,
they just kind of picked a name for a
really great recipe where they were able
to actually using only one model
instead of a multistep process,
actually generate realistic images
of faces and things like that. Um,
that was sort of like the beginning
of the Cambrian explosion of Gans.
Like, you know, once, once you
had animals that had a backbone,
you suddenly got lots of different
versions of, of, you know,
like fish and four legged
animals and things like that. So,
so DC Gann became kind of the backbone
for many different models that came out
used as a baseline even still. Yeah. Yeah.
And so from there I would say some
interesting things we've seen are um,
there's a lot you can say about how
just the quality of standard image
generation Ganz has increased.
But what's also maybe more interesting
on an intellectual level is how the
things you can use gowns
for has also changed. Um,
one thing is that you can use them to
learn classifiers without having to have
class labels for every example in your,
your training set.
So that's called semi supervised
learning. Um, my colleague at open Ai,
Tim Solomons,
who's at brain now a,
wrote a paper called improved
techniques for training. Gans um,
I'm a coauthor on this paper,
but I can't claim any credit
for this particular part. Uh,
one thing he showed in the paper is that
you can take the Gan discriminator and
use it as a classifier that actually
tells you, you know, this image is a cat,
this image is a dark, this image is a
car, this image is a truck. And so on.
Not just to say whether
the image is real or fake,
but if it is real to say specifically
what kind of object it is.
And he found that you can train these
classifiers with far fewer labeled
examples then traditional classifiers.
So a few supervise based on also not
just your discrimination ability,
but your ability to classify,
you going to do much,
you're going to conversion much faster
to being effective at being at this
command. Yeah. So for
example, for the MDS data set,
you want to look at an image
of a handwritten digit and
say whether it's a zero,
a one or a two and so on.
Um,
to get down to less than
1% accuracy required around
60,000 examples until maybe
about 2014 or so in 2016 with this
a semi supervised Gannon project,
Tim was able to get below 1% error,
uh,
using only a hundred labeled examples.
So that was about a 600 x decrease in
the amount of labels that he needed.
He's still using more images in that,
but he doesn't need to have each of them
labeled. As you know, this one's a one,
this one's a two, this one's a
zero and so on. Then to be able to,
for gas to be able to generate
recognizable objects, so objects from
a particular class,
you still need labeled data because
you need to know what it means to be a
particular class cat dog. How do you
think we can move away from that?
Yeah.
Some researchers at Brain Zurich actually
just released a really great paper on
a semi supervised gans where their,
their goal isn't to classify,
it's to make recognizable objects
despite not having a lot of labeled data.
They were working off of deep mines began
project and they showed that they can
match the performance of big began
using only 10%, I believe of the,
of the labels. A big gun was
trained on the image net Dataset,
which is about 1.2 million images
and had all of them labeled, um,
this latest project from brains direct
shows that they're able to get away with
only having about 10% of the,
uh, of the images labeled.
And they do that essentially using a,
a clustering algorithm where
the discriminator learns
to assign the objects to
groups.
And then this understanding that objects
can be grouped into similar types helps
it to for more realistic ideas of what
should be appearing in the image because
it knows that every image it creates has
to come from one of these architectural
groups rather than just
being some arbitrary image.
If you train again with no class labels,
you tend to get things that look sort
of like grass or water or brick or dirt.
But, um, but without necessarily
a lot going on in them.
And I think that's partly because if
you look at a large image, that image,
the object doesn't necessarily
occupy the whole image.
And so you learn to create
realistic sets of Pixels,
but you don't necessarily learn that
the object is the star of the show.
And he wanted to be in
every image you make.
Yeah. You've, I've heard
you talk about the, uh,
the horse to zebra cycle again
mapping and how it turns out,
uh,
again thought provoking that horses are
usually on grass and zebras are usually
on dry terrain. So when you're
doing that kind of generation,
you're going to end up generating
greener horses or whatever.
Uh, and so those are connected together.
It's not just, yeah, you can be able to,
you're not able to segment, uh, be
able to generate in a segment way.
So are there other types of games
you've come across in your mind, uh,
that, uh, neural networks can
play with each other to, uh,
uh, to, uh, to be able to solve problems?
Yeah. The, the one that I spent
most of my time on is in security.
You can muddle most interactions as a
game where there's attacker is trying to
break your system and you are the defender
trying to build a resilient system.
Um, there's also domain
adversarial learning, which is uh,
an approach to a domain adaptation that
looks really a lot like gans. Uh, the,
the authors,
the idea before the Gan paper came out
with their paper came out a little bit
later. Um, and you know, they,
they were very nice and cited again paper,
but I know that they actually had
the idea before I came out. Um,
domain adaptation is when you want to
train a machine learning model in one,
one setting called a domain and then
deploy it in another domain later and he
would like it to perform well in the
new domain even though the new domain is
different from how it was
trained. Um, so for example,
you might want to train on a really
clean image dataset like image net,
but then deploy on users' phones where
the user is taking pictures in the dark
pictures.
We'll move in quickly and just pictures
that aren't really centered or composed
all that well.
When you take a normal
machine learning model,
it often degrades really badly when you
moved to the new domain because it looks
so different from what
the model is trained on.
A domain adaptation algorithms
try to smooth out that gap.
And the domain adversarial approach is
based on training a feature extractor
where the features have the same
statistics regardless of which domain you
extracted them on.
So in the domain adversarial game,
you have one player that's a feature
extractor and another player that's a
domain recognizer.
Uh,
the domain recognizer wants to look at
the output of the feature extractor and
guests, which of the two domains,
oh, the features came from.
So it's a lot like the real versus
fake discriminator in Gans. Uh,
and then the feature extractor you can
think of as loosely analogous to the
generator and gans, except
what's trying to do here is, uh,
both full the domain recognizer and to
not knowing which domain the data came
from and also extract features
that are good for classification.
So at the end of the day you can,
in in the cases where it works out,
you can actually get um,
features that work about
the same in both domains.
Sometimes this has a drawback where in
order to make things work the same in
both domains,
it just gets worse at the first one.
But there are a lot of cases where
it actually works out well on both.
Do you think of gas being useful in
the context of data augmentation? Yeah.
One thing you could hope for with Ganz
is you could imagine I've got a limited
training set and I'd like to make more
training data to train something else,
like a classifier.
You could train the Gan on the training
set and then create more data and then
maybe the classifier would perform better
on the test set after training on this
bigger generate a data set. Uh,
so that's the simplest version of,
of something you might hope would work.
I've never heard of that
particular approach working.
But I think there's some,
there's some closely related things that
that I think could work in the future
and some that actually
already have worked. Um,
so if you think a little bit about
what we'd be hoping for for use,
again to make more training data,
we're hoping that the Gan will generalize
to new examples better than the
classifier would have generalized
if it was trained on the same data.
And I don't know of any reason to believe
that again would generalize better
than the class of firewood.
Um,
but what we might hope for is that the
gun could generalize differently from a
specific classifier.
So one thing I think is worth trying to,
I haven't personally tried,
but someone could try is what have
you trained a whole lot of different
generative models on
the same training set,
create samples from all of them and
then train a classifier on that.
Because each of the generative models
might generalize in a slightly different
way.
They might capture many different axes
of variation that one individual model
wouldn't.
And then the classifier can capture all
of those ideas by training on all of
their data.
So it'd be a little bit like making an
ensemble of classifiers and I think that
Ganz, yeah, in a way I think
that could generalize better.
The other thing that gans
are really good for is um,
not necessarily generating new data
that's exactly like what you already have,
but by a generating new data that has
different properties from the data you
already had.
One thing that you can do is you can
create differentially private data.
So suppose that you have something like
medical records and you don't want to
train a classifier on the medical
records and then publish the classifier
because someone might be able to reverse
engineer some of the medical records
you trained on.
Uh,
there's a paper from Casey Greens lab
that shows how you can train again using
differential privacy.
And then the samples from,
again still have the same differential
privacy guarantees as the parameters of,
again,
so you can make a fake patient data for
other researchers to use and they can do
almost anything they want with that data.
Because it doesn't come from real people.
And the differential privacy mechanism
gives you clear guarantees on how much
the original peoples
data has been protected.
That's really interesting. Actually. I
haven't heard you talk about that before.
Um, in terms of fairness,
a scene from a triple AI,
your talk,
how can adversarial machine learning
help models beef more fair? Well,
the respect of sensitive variables.
Yeah.
So there's a paper from Amos Starkey's
lab about how to learn machine learning
models that are incapable of using
specific variables. So say for example,
you want it to make predictions
that are not affected by gender. Um,
it isn't enough to just leave gender
out of the input to the model.
You can often infer gender from
a lot of other characteristics,
like say that you have the person's name,
but you're not told their gender.
Well if, if their name is Ian,
they're kind of obviously a man. Um,
so what you'd like to do is make a machine
learning model that can still take in
a lot of different attributes and make
it really accurate informed prediction,
but be confident that it isn't reverse
engineering gender or another sensitive
variable internally.
You can do that using something very
similar to the domain adversarial approach
where you have one player that's a feature
extractor and another player that's a
feature analyzer and you want to make
sure that the feature analyzer is not able
to guess the value of the sensitive
variable that you're trying keep private.
Right. That's, yeah. I love this
approach. So what do, yeah. With the,
with the feature, uh, you're
not able to infer, right?
This sensitive variables. Yeah. Brilliant.
That's quite, quite brilliant and simple.
Actually.
Another way I think that
gans in particular could be
used for fairness would be
to make something like a cycle again where
you can take data from one domain and
convert it into another. We've seen
cycle again turning horses into zebras.
We've seen, uh, other
unsupervised gans made by menu.
Lou doing things like turning
day photos into night photos. Um,
I think for fairness,
you could imagine taking records for
people in one group and transforming them
into analogous people in another group
and testing to see if there there are
treated equitably across those two groups.
There's a lot of things it'd be hard
to get right to make sure that the
conversion process
itself is fair. Uh, and,
and I don't think it's anywhere near
something that we could actually use yet.
But if you could design that conversion
process very carefully and might give
you a way of doing audits where you say,
what if we took people from this group,
converted them into equivalent
people in another group?
Does this system actually
treat them how it ought to?
That's also really interesting,
you know, in, in a popular,
in popular press and in
general in our imagination,
you think a well gans are able to
generate data and you start to think about
deep fakes or being able to sort of
maliciously generate data that fakes the
identity of other people.
Is this something of a concern to you?
Is this something,
if you look 10 20 years into the future,
is that something that pops up in your
work and the work of the community that's
working on January models?
I'm a lot less concerned about 20
years from now then the next few years.
I think there'll be a kind
of bumpy cultural transition
as people encounter this
idea that there can be very realistic
videos and audio that aren't real.
I think 20 years from now people will
mostly understand that you shouldn't
believe something is real just
because you saw a video of it,
people will expect to see that it's
been cryptographically signed, uh, or,
or have some other mechanism to make
them believe that the content is real.
Um,
there's already people working on this,
like there's a startup called trupick
that provides a lot of mechanisms for
authenticating that an
image is real there.
There may be not quite up to
having a state actor tried to,
to evade their, their
verification techniques, but uh,
it's not that people are already
working on and I think we'll get right
eventually.
So you think authentication will,
will eventually win out.
So being able to authenticate it,
this is real and this is not, yeah,
as opposed to gans just getting better
and better or generative models being
able to get better and better to
where the nature of what is real.
I just don't think
you'll ever be able look at the pixels
of a photo and tell you for sure that
it's real or not real.
And I think it would actually
be a somewhat dangerous
to rely on that approach
too much.
Um,
if you make a really good fake detector
and then someone's able to full your
thick detector and your fake
detector says this image is not fake,
then it's even more credible than if
you've never made a thick detector in the
first place. What I do
think we'll get to is, um,
systems that we can kind of
use behind the scenes for,
to make estimates of what's going on and
maybe not like use them in court for a
definitive analysis.
I also think we will likely get
better authentication systems where,
uh,
you know,
if imagine that every phone
cryptographically signs
everything that comes out of
it, uh, you wouldn't able to
conclusively tell that an image was real,
but you would be able to tell somebody
who knew the appropriate private key for
this phone,
uh,
was actually able to sign this image
and upload it to this server at this
timestamp. Right. Um,
so you could imagine maybe you make
phones that have the private keys hardware
embedded in them.
Um,
if like a state security agency really
wants to infiltrate the company,
they could probably,
you know,
planet private key of their choice or
break open the chip and learn the private
key or something like that.
But it would make it a lot harder for an
adversary with fewer resources to fake
things for most of us
who, yeah. Okay. Okay.
So you mentioned the beer and
the bar and the new ideas.
You are able to implement this or come
up with this new idea pretty quickly and
implemented pretty quickly.
Do you think there are still many such
groundbreaking ideas and deep learning
that could be developed so quickly?
Yeah,
I do think that there are a lot of ideas
that can be developed really quickly.
Gans we're probably a little
bit of an outlier on the whole,
like one hour timescale,
but um,
just in terms of like low resource I
ideas where you do something really
different on the algorithm scale
and get an a big payback. Um,
I think it's not as likely that you'll
see that in terms of things like core
machine learning technologies,
like a better classifier or a better
reinforcement learning algorithm or a
better generative model. Um,
if I had the gun idea today,
it'd be a lot harder to prove that it
was useful than it was back in 2014
because I would need to get it running
on something like image net or sell a bay
at high resolution. You know, those
take a while to train. You couldn't,
you couldn't train it in an hour and
know that it was something really new and
exciting. Uh, back in 2014
treading on amnesty was enough.
But there are other areas of machine
learning where I think a new idea could
actually be developed really
quickly with low resources.
What's your intuition about what areas
of machine learning are ripe for this?
Yeah, so I think, um, fairness and uh,
interpretability are areas where we just
really don't have any idea how anything
should be done yet.
Like for interpretability,
I don't think we even have
the right definitions and
even just defining a really
useful concept,
you don't even need to run any experiments
could have a huge impact on the field.
We've seen that, for example,
in differential privacy that uh,
Cynthia Dwork and her collaborators made
this technical definition of privacy
where before a lot of
things are really mushy.
And then with that definition you could
actually design randomized algorithms
for accessing databases and guarantee
that they preserved individual people's
privacy in a,
in like a mathematical quantitative sense.
Right now we all talk a lot about how
interpretable different machine learning
algorithms are,
but it's really just people's opinion
and everybody probably has a different
idea of what interpretability
means in their head.
If we could define some concept
related to interpretability,
that's actually measurable,
that would be a huge leap forward.
Even without a new algorithm
that increases that quantity.
And also once, once we had the
definition of differential privacy,
it was fast to get the
algorithms that guaranteed it.
So you could imagine once we have
definitions of good concepts and
interpretability,
we might be able to provide the
algorithms that have the interpretability
guarantees quickly too.
What do you think it takes to build a
system with human level intelligence as we
quickly venture into the philosophical,
so artificial general intelligence
when you get to take, um, I,
I think that it definitely takes a better
environments than we currently have
for training agents.
That we want them to have a really
wide diversity of experiences. Uh,
I also think it's going to take
really a lot of computation.
It's hard to imagine exactly how much,
so you're optimistic about simulation
simulating a variety of environments.
Is the path forward as opposed to it's
a necessary ingredient? Yeah, I, I,
I don't think that we're going to get
to artificial general intelligence by
training on fixed datasets or, or by
thinking really hard about the problem.
I think that the agent really needs
to interact and have a variety of
experiences within the same a lifespan.
And today we have many different models
that can each do one thing and we tend
to train them on one dataset
or one RL environment. Um,
sometimes they're actually papers about
getting one set of perimeters to perform
well in many different RL environments,
but we don't really have anything like
an agent that goes seamlessly from one
type of experience to another and,
and really integrates all the different
things that it does over the course of
its life. Uh, when we do see
multi-agent environments,
they tend to be, um, there's so
many, uh, multi environment agents.
They tend to be similar environments.
Like all,
all of them are playing like an
action based game. Right? Um,
we don't really have an agent
that goes from, you know,
playing a video game to like
reading the Wall Street Journal, uh,
to predicting how effective a molecule
will be as a drug or something like that.
What do you think is a good test
for intelligence in you view?
Spend a lot of benchmarks
started with the, uh,
with Alan Turing and natural
conversation and being good,
being a good benchmark for intelligence.
What are,
what would a
uh,
Ian Goodfellow sit back and be really
damn impressed if a system was able to
accomplish,
um, something that doesn't take a
lot of glue from human engineers.
So imagine that instead
of having to go to the,
uh,
CFR website and download CFR 10 and then
write a python script to parse it and
all that,
you could just point an agent at the
CFR 10 problem and it downloads and
extracts the data and trains a model
and starts giving you predictions. Um,
I feel like something that doesn't
need to have every step of the pipeline
assembled for it. Definitely understand.
So what it's doing is auto Amelle moving,
right?
So that direction are you thinking wave
bigger? Mel has mostly
been moving toward, um,
once we've built all the glue, can
the machine learning system, uh,
to design the architecture really well?
And so I'm more of saying like,
if something knows how to preprocess
the data so that it successfully
accomplishes the task,
then it would be very hard to argue that
it doesn't truly understand the task in
some fundamental sense.
And I don't necessarily know that that's
like the philosophical definition of
intelligence, but that's something
that'd be really cool to build.
That'd be really useful
and would impress me.
And when he convinced me that we've
made a step forward in real AI,
so you give it
the URL for Wikipedia and then,
uh,
at next day expect it to
be able to solve CFR 10
or like you type in a paragraph explaining
what you want it to do and it figures
out what web searches it should
run and downloads all the,
all the necessary ingredients.
So, uh, you have a very clear,
calm way of speaking.
No ums, easy to edit.
I've seen comments for both you and I,
uh,
have been identified as both
potentially being robots.
If you have to prove to the world that
you are indeed human, how would you do it?
Uh, well I can understand
thinking that I'm a robot.
It's the flip side. Turing
test I think. Yeah. Yeah.
The proof prove you're human test.
Um,
she see you have to,
uh,
is there something that's truly
unique in your mind? I suppose as it,
does it go back to just natural
language again, just being able to, uh,
proving that I'm not a robot with today's
technology know that's pretty straight
forward. Like my conversation today
hasn't veered off into, you know,
talking about the stock
market or something because
it was in my training data.
But I guess more generally trying to
prove that something is real from the
content alone,
it was incredibly hard.
That's one of the main things I've
gotten out of Mike and Research that
you can simulate almost anything.
And so you have to really step back to
a separate channel to prove that song is
real.
So like,
I guess I should have had myself stepped
on a blockchain when I was born or
something, but I didn't do that. So I
coined to my own research methodology.
There's just no way to know
at this point. So what, uh,
last question problem stands off for
you that you're really excited about
challenging in the near future? So I think
a resistance to adversarial examples,
figuring out how to make machine learning
secure against an adversary who wants
to interfere it and control with it is,
uh,
one of the most important
things researchers today
could solve in all domains,
in image language driving and every,
I guess I'm most concerned about domains
we haven't really encountered yet. Like,
like imagine 20 years from now when we're
using advanced AI is to do things we
haven't even thought of yet.
Um,
like if you ask people what
are the important problems
in security of phones in
like 2002, I don't think we would have
anticipated that we're using them for,
you know, nearly as many things
as we're using them for today.
I think it's going to be like that with
AI that you can kind of try to speculate
about where it's going.
But really the business opportunities
that end up taking off would be hard to
predict ahead of time.
Well you can predict ahead of time is
that almost anything you can do with
machine learning,
you would like to make sure that people
can't get it to do what they want rather
than what you want. Just by showing it a
funny QR code or a funny input pattern.
And you think that this set
of methodologies to do that,
it can be bigger than any one domain. And
that's the thing. So yeah. Yeah. Like, um,
one methodology that I think is not,
not a specific methodology be like a
category of solutions that I'm excited
about today was making dynamic models
that change every time they make a
prediction. So right now we tend to train
models and then after they're trained,
we freeze them and we just use the same
rule to classify everything that comes
in from then on. Uh, that's
really a sitting duck from
a security point of view.
Uh, if you always output the same
answer for the same input, um,
then people can just run and puts
through until they find a mistake that
benefits them and then they use the same
mistake over and over and over again.
Um, I think having a model that updates
its predictions so that it's harder to
predict what you're going to get.
We'll make it harder for the,
for an adversary to really take control
of the system and make it do what they
want it to do. Yeah.
Models that maintain a,
a bit of a sense of mystery about them
cause they always keep changing. Yeah.
And thanks so much for talking today.
That was awesome. Thank you for coming in.
That's
great to see you.